Cinq ans après sa première vidéo
que devient le corps de Cyprien ?
Comment évolue-t-il ?
Que des questions que personne ne se pose.
Oui bon ça va, pas besoin d'être
désagréable non plus, merci.
Je me suis dit, voilà
j'ai dépassé 30 ans
c'est peut-être le moment
de faire un peu le bilan
de vous expliquer un petit peu les nouveautés
quant à mon corps
et comment j'ai aussi perdu presque 10 kilos
Je vous en parle à la fin de la vidéo.
Déjà : je suis en très bonne santé
et ça c'est excellent.
Ensuite y'a des choses qui ont évolué
pas que en bien, malheureusement.
Et des choses qui ont pas du tout bougé
je pense notamment à
la transpiration excessive
mon corps en fait toujours des caisses
en termes de transpiration.
Je sais pas pourquoi.
Cyprien va se lever de sa chaise
j'envoie l’information aux muscles.
On a besoin de moi ?
Non.
Tu sais que si tu veux
tu peux activer un tout
petit peu le levier.
Oui.
J’aime bien.
Désolé.
La pilosité, ça ne s'arrange pas.
Ma barbe prend du terrain
mes poils de torse aussi
j’ai l'impression que les
deux veulent se rejoindre
Pour je ne sais pas
un moment convivial.
Torse, on peut le faire !
Que quelques centimètres, vas-y !
On y est presque !
On l’a fait !
Je peux me joindre à vous ?
Bien sûr !
D'ailleurs en parlant de pilosité
il faut que je vous l’avoue
je commence à avoir des
poils sur les oreilles.
C'est du duvet un peu dégueulasse
qui commence à avoir
des poils un peu long
un peu blanc quand il ya du soleil
Si c’est pour avoir les oreilles
de Baby Yoda
C'est pas la peine, non merci.
Alors moi je demande
tout simplement
un service après vente de mon corps.
Au moins pour poser des questions.
Oui bonjour, installez vous.
Ça vous a plu le monosourcil ?
C'était mon idée.
Non ça c'était une idée de merde.
À propos des poils
- moi je
- Vous avez froid ?
Non.
Vous avez un petit peu
froid je suis sûr.
On peut rajouter des poils pour
vous tenir au chaud
Non, je ne veux pas
plus de poils.
Je vais bien.
- J’ai pas
- Et là vous avez froid.
Mais forcément vous venez de
mettre un ventilateur.
Ça n’a pas de sens.
Voilà c’est bien ce que je disais
vous avez froid, surtout aux oreilles.
- Non.
- Sylvie ?
Rajoutez des poils aux oreilles
- il a froid aux oreilles le pauvre.
- Non.
Vous êtes un peu frileux
des orteils.
Non, j’ai froid pareil partout !
En termes de poil je vous
mets tout.
On garde juste la paume des mains,
c’est plus joli.
Oui Sylvie ?
Mettez des poils partout
sauf dans la paume des mains.
Ah oui petit fait surprenant chez moi
quand je baille, je pleure.
Vous allez me dire “c’est normal”
mais moi je pleure beaucoup
des grosses larmes qui
coulent sur les joues
et d'ailleurs depuis que je suis gamin
au collège, au lycée, au travail
il m’est arrivé plein de fois
cette situation.
Le chat je m’en bat les couilles
mais c’est le chat de ma meuf
tu comprends...
Ça va Cyprien ?
Qu’est-ce qu’il t’arrive ?
Tu tu veux qu'on en parle ?
c'est un problème de coeur ?
Un problème familial peut-être ?
Non je me fais chier, c’est tout.
Tu veux pas en parler.
Je comprends.
Il y a plein de gens qui pensent
que je me mets à chialer
d’un coup comme ça.
Pourquoi j'ai autant de larmes ?
C'est à cause de lui.
Je sais pas ce qu'il a avec
ce levier mais il est...
Hé, c’est une chialeuse !
En parlant des nouveautés
il m’arrive truc assez
bizarre en ce moment.
Alors je vous explique quand j'étais gamin
j'avais des pellicules
Guten tag, ich bien Hans
le designer du corps de Cyprien
vous me connaisez.
J'ai intégré un système
de particules
qui tombent des cheveux.
sehr pratique pour retrouver
son chemin
quand il est perdu dans la forêt.
Bon ensuite j'ai utilisé du
shampooing antipelliculaire
du coup c’était réglé
Was ? Nein ! Nein !
Qu’est-ce qu’il est futé !
Mon système ingénieux !
Tombé à l’eau ! Warum ?
Donc moi j’étais tranquille,
pépouze
les années passent, tout va bien
et là, depuis quelques temps
je retrouve des pellicules sur
mes vêtements.
D’où ça vient ?
C’est quoi ce bordel ?
Les pellicules de barbe !
Tu l’as pas vu arriver
celle-là, na-ja !
C’est mon invention !
Des pellicules qui tombent
directement de la barbe.
T’as voulu me n* la gueule ?
On l’a fait pas à Hans.
C’est pas une blague.
Ma barbe fait des pellicules.
Ça fait longtemps.
Si quelqu’un a une solution
je suis preneur.
On reste dans le poil avec
une question
que pas mal de gens de posent,
pas mal de mecs surtout.
Vais-je perdre mes cheveux ?
Clairement pour moi
il ya deux voies possibles :
Soit je deviens comme mon
grand-père maternel
beaucoup de cheveux sur
la tête, y a pas de souci
soit
comme mon père.
Pas besoin de shéma, il reste
plus grand chose
désolé papa, tu éblouis quand
il y a du soleil.
Du coup je suis dans
cette incertitude
je suis à un moment de
ma vie où je suis comme ça
on sait pas trop
surtout que mon père ne
m’aide pas du tout.
Clairement.
Dis-moi papa, j’ai retrouvé
une photo de toi
et à tout hasard, tu avais
quel âge dessus ?
Oh, j’avais encore
un peu de cheveux.
Je dirais...
28 ans.
T’étais plus jeune que moi alors.
Ou 35.
Soit précis papa, tu avais
quel âge dessus ?
Je sais plus, entre
25 et 35.
Sois précis papa !
- On s’en fout.
- Non on s’en fout pas.
Tu peux pas comprendre.
Écoute fils. Je comprends
tout à fait.
Dis-moi papa
T’avais quel âge sur cette
photo en noir et blanc ?
Oh, c’est moi.
Entre 10 et 40.
Tu sauras jamais.
you never know my son
Parlons des changements.
Depuis quelques années j'ai
perdu une dizaine de kilos
je suis passé d’à peu près 80 kg à 70
Je sais que les gens adorent
les “avant-après”
donc voilà : avant, après.
j'ai pas spécialement changé
mon alimentation
parce que chez moi les
régimes ça marche pas.
Quand je me restreins, derrière
je mange deux fois plus
le yo-yo, tu connais.
Par contre j'ai changé quelque
chose dans mon quotidien.
Qu'est-ce donc ? Quel est son secret ?
Tout le monde veut savoir.
Est-ce une technique
ancestrale roumaine ?
Va-t-il partager avec nous
cette information incroyable ?
Êtes-vous prêt à découvrir
ma technique ultime ?
Les médecins le détestent.
Secret dévoilé dans 3...
2...
Petit suspense.
1...
Je me déplace en vélo.
Pas mal comme secret.
C’est tout, je vais au
boulot en vélo
je vais mais rendez-vous
en vélo.
Quelle vitesse incroyable !
ça fait entre 40 minutes et
1h30 de vélo par jour
je sais que c'est décevant
Je n'ai pas de programme secret
je suis désolé !
Ensuite vient la question du muscle.
J'ai essayé plusieurs procédés :
d'abord la salle de sport.
Djé ! T’as vu qui il y a
à la salle de sport ?
Il y a Cyprien, le youtubeur
Je fais une story, direct.
Hé ! Y’a Cyprien le youtubeur
à la salle de sport
il sue comme un gros porc
regardez sa gueule, wesh.
Comme vous avez pu comprendre
ça me correspondait pas beaucoup
alors j’ai essayé un autre procédé
la salle de sport très chère.
Gontran, observe qui est là.
C'est le troubadour du web là,
comment il s'appelle...
Norman.
Il faut que je fasse un vidéogramme
pour la cousinade.
Salut Cassiopée, salut Balthazar
regardez qui est là, l’autre
con d’internet.
Bof, ensuite j’ai eu un coach
à domicile
une fois par semaine
et maintenant pour me muscler
j'ai un nouveau truc que
j'ai un peu du mal à assumer, j'avoue.
J’ai des grosses courbatures
de la séance d’hier
Ouais moi aussi j’ai
des courbatures.
Ah bon, tu vas à la salle ?
Non.
Moi je fais du
Ring-Fit.
dépenses-toi tout en accomplissant
des objectifs ludiques
utilise ton corps
pour terrasser les monstres
qui te barrent la route
avec Ring-Fit.
Bah ok...
En même temps, si tu te
sens bien avec le
Ring-Fit
je suis passé niveau 2
en faisant du gainage.
Félicitation !
Qu’est-ce qu’on s’amuse !
Tout en faisant une
activité sportive !
Vous moquez pas !
pendant le confinement moi
ça m’a beaucoup aidé
ça m’a occupé.
D'ailleurs c'est pas un placement de produit
Donc si Nintendo vous voulez
me filer des thunes
j'accepte quand même.
C’est pas trop tard.
Voilà maintenant mon corps
n'a plus de secret pour vous
le plus important je dirais que c'est
d'être bien dans son corps
tout simplement. Il faut
l’assumer.
Et pourquoi pas un nouveau bilan
dans quelques années
pour savoir comment ça évolue.
Vais-je perdre mes cheveux ?
Vais-je me muscler encore plus ?
Reprendre du poids ?
On ne sait pas.
En attendant, abonne-toi.